hervé théry bonjour un duel lula vole
sonar ou en 2022 fiction ou réalité
je cite avec cette décision la cour
suprême de la cour suprême lula est
candidat c'est ce cafouillis terrain
djerbal sonar ou le parent est très
probable effectivement c'était
l'opposition n'arrive absolument pas à
s'unir
là elle a son candidat et donc ça va
être très probablement savent il ya eu
tellement déjà de retournement de la
voir quelqu'un quelques doutes ce qui a
été fait hier c'est que la cour suprême
en plénier a confirmé la décision qui
avait été prise par un seul juge et ça
ne s'adapte soupe al oula ça oblige à
refaire tout le processus mais pendant
ce temps là il est con présumé innocent
et donc il pourra être candidat c'est
justement quelles suites judiciaires
pour lula puisque vous l'avez dit n'est
pas absolu ou encore san absous par an
non c'est l'inaction qui avait été jugée
à curitiba qui a été cassé et tout ça va
être tout un va être repris à brasilia
mais ça m'est très longtemps et donc ce
sera probablement pas fait avant
l'élection et une partie des charges
seront prescrites mais il a encore
plusieurs procès sur le dos pour des
affaires de corruption assez mineur et
qui peuvent être sérieusement embêtante
pour lui et comment la population
brésilienne accueil à la décision de la
cour suprême à ceux qui ont voté pour
ben also know sont très tristes ceux qui
ont voté pour lui sont très contents ou
pour ses successeurs
le brésil est très divisée en ce moment
et la nouveauté c'est que la popularité
de bolsenheim qui s'était bien maintenue
grâce au secours d'urgence qu'il a
distribués ou fait distribuer est en
train de chuter à grande vitesse il est
passé de 40 à 20% quelques semaines et
donc 6 l'élection avait lieu aujourd'hui
il serait battu
mais la question c'est il avait été lue
par roger du parti des travailleurs dont
beaucoup de gens avaient dit ou plutôt
que le parti des travailleurs est
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui pensent
encore ça et d'autres qui disent tous
plutôt que gossau nabeul et donc le
doute ça va être lequel des deux rejet
est le plus fort le parti des
travailleurs le camp de lula outre ce
duel annoncé donc entre lula et déjà
hier vol sonar ou aucune autre
personnalité politique est en mesure de
se dégager de se positionner pour pour
2022 en gros je dis il ya l'ultra-gauche
un côté l'ultra droite de l'autre il n'y
a pas d'alternative possible le centre
n'existe pas au brésil ce qu'on appelle
le sang c'est un mélange de et
d'une association de petits partis sans
beaucoup de scrupules et sans beaucoup
de parties ils sont toujours prêts à se
vendre au plus offrant mais il ya
quelques candidats possibles comme si
logo mais cela était il ya quelques
années et surtout le gouverneur de
l'état de san parle sans parle c'est 40
millions d'habitants c'est le coeur
économique du brésil lui ça pourrait
être un concurrent sérieux style ou là
n'étaient pas là avec lula je pense
qu'il a pas beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir se poser d'ici la présidentielle
de 2022
il va se passer encore des semaines des
mois c'est encore long qu'est ce qu'il
peut se passer encore selon vous on sait
qu'elle a créé dudu coronavirus
d'ailleurs lula attaques souvent là
dessus son adversaire djerbal senard
haut et puis on l'a dit également il ya
la suite judiciaire pour pour lula
qu'est ce qui peut se passer encore
selon vous quels sont les scénarios
étaient possibles des possibles on a on
peut même pas évident
évacuer complètement l'idée d'un
attentant puisque j'avais molson avait
pris un coup de couteau dans la campagne
précédente
il peut y avoir un engouement pour un
troisième candidat
lula qui est pas tout jeune peut avoir
un accident de santé tout est possible
et l'armée pourrait en fait aussi en jeu
puisque lula jusque molson a réussi à se
fâcher avec une partie de l'armée qui
avaient tous les trois chefs des trois
armes et ont démissionné massivement il
ya quelques jours
donc c'est vraiment un schéma absolument
ouvert le plus probable c'est
effectivement le duel
quand on part mais je ne ferme aucune
autre port tout est possible c'est un
pays très imprévisible merci invétéré
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes un géographe et
professeur à l'université de sao paulo
au brésil